more than everyone a few words I want to
say five years today I lost my firstborn
my only son it was a day I thought I
would never see my day that has changed
my life forever although although I have
been forced to learn how to cope with
his absence I would never guessed the
fact that my son would no longer be her
and justice has not been served my son
deserves to live a full life but a
coward would have bad shows to value his
life not to value its life sorry my son
was murdered in cold blood with no
remorse and no medical treatment Mike
might laid in the street for four and a
half hours as he later he was
dehumanized and disrespected neither of
us as parents were given a chance to
hold him identify his lifeless body no
answers no apology no justice so I stand
here today to discuss the unsaid is I'm
satisfied with the way my son death was
handled and I do and I am demanding
evidence to be reanalyzed and
accountability to follow as a follow
father our value
as a father I vowed to protect my
children
we're on August 9th 2014 that wasn't the
case I could not protect you that day
and it breaks my heart
I was standing fighting til the day I
die for justice not too much has changed
my son was not the first to die by the
hands of those who vowed to protect and
serve and sadly he won't be the last
if any if anyone is confused about the
fact but Mike Brown's murder they just
need to spend one hour and 30 minutes
watching stranger fruit all the facts of
the murder or clearly lied up my son
deserve justice it's unbelievable to the
family and its a person to the city that
stranger fruit has been on TV for a year
and all the evidence or on to my son's
murder and the whole nation knows the
truth yet this city still continues to
do nothing so I'm requesting for Wesley
Bell to reopen this case
any question some sort
I definitely had a conversation with him
that's why I say this is not an attack
but I think processes need to be speeded
up definitely people who are funding
Humber has to check that the evidence
clearly go through with all the
paperwork and make sure that it's able
to be open if it's able to be open we
have a day in court if it's not he said
we just won't be doing anything but what
I am here today in front of you all and
the world to demand someone to look at
the case
well it definitely everyone like those
on the force the evidence does not match
up
have you watched stranger fruit check it
out we're definitely you know everyone
covered up from the chief all the way up
to the guy that used to sit in his
office everyone covered they ever did so
definitely definitely you know we have a
problem we had a problem investigator
come in definitely they said that his
hands was up the way the entries was in
and out his arms so that's a surrender
pose and he still was killed
like I say this is not an ambush on
Westie bill I definitely respect this
man as a man you know hopefully that he
can see something that was flawed and we
could reopen this case well you know
what I still stand strong
I still stand tall ten toes down I'm not
gonna stop
you know still black and brown bodies
are still being found on the ground you
know so until we started getting more
communication on the on the police side
you know I'm not going to say that we
don't we're not even fought on certain
things but I think the badge and the
uniform is what skirts are people I
still French you know so just be totally
patrolling streets and not interacting
with the community of course we're still
gonna be in a in a currency mode you
know so somebody gotta stored and I
think you need to strut with them that
its father still standing his family is
still standing and we're not stopping
until we get some type of justice
yeah I don't read I did a lot of
research of course of course of course
have you read you need to read them you
need to do some research brother yes
I deputy had it I definitely had a
conversation with him and it was just a
misunderstanding
you know Mike did not strong-arm this is
just what the the media put out false
false
I definitely don't feel like he owes me
nothing but I don't think that he just
need to do his job
no sir we'll take one last question and
then we can cover the vets and we have
to move to can fill
well that's what Jen was gonna talk
about that the idea - okay any more
questions okay thank you
thank you again for being here to cover
this announcement and to cover our
Memorial weekend today we have our press
conference here we'll leave immediately
go to Canfield where you can set up in
the crew pit across from the rope'n
stanchions to cover all our events 11
a.m. in Canfield at the memorial site we
will have our memorial and this is
featuring many special people this year
it's different than we've had before and
very special and we hope that you guys
all come out and join us it is from 11
o'clock to 12:20 and after that convenes
then we will move at 1 o'clock over to
the Sam's meat market parking lot at
9241
West Florissant and there will have our
MB to market it's a big community day we
have an amazing group of community over
30 vendors that have come together to be
a blessing to the community to give
resources to hand out giveaways we have
free food for kids in Canfield and in
Ferguson from 10 a.m. to 8:30 tonight
ice cream for Ben and Jerry's bounce
houses music family fun a great
gathering to bring the community
together but Cal brown Michael's wife
stands here beside us and we talked
about humanizing that's one of the
biggest points of this entire Memorial
weekend our goal is to reunite Brown jr.
many of you or your stations or media in
general took a lot of time in during
this case and after August 9th 2014 to
dehumanize Mike Brown jr. to not see
this 18 year old boy as a young man a
human being with family with a baby
sister that was one at the time brothers
and sisters many fathers mothers and his
people that loved him friends all of
that and so Mike had likes and desires
and he was going to vad Arak College for
HVAC he loved to do rap and to all his
loves and likes Cal envisioned brought
together in our exhibit the exhibit is
called as I see you exhibit a trip
- my crown jr. that will be at the Urban
League in Ferguson today through Sunday
so you can come out from 1:00 to 6:00 to
see the exhibit there and then tomorrow
Saturday a Sunday from 10:00 to 4:00 so
we thank you all again for coming out
today and any more questions we can
answer for you in Canfield thank you
if you have any questions about the
events that was just a question that's
asked you can visit our Facebook page or
I gave you my phone number
earlier you can always send me a text
but there's signs all out and cans
filled with all of our events